[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Lara's in
Sarasota hi Laura welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi Dave how are you better than we
deserve what's
up so I have a question we're paying off
the L of our debt I have about 66,000 on
my car I just wanted to know do you
think I should be able to get my nails
done while I do
that I am unqualified to answer this
question as I am to answer can I get my
hair done when you uh do this so however
Jade is sitting next to me with
fluorescent Nails she is qualified uh so
what Sam and I did when we were paying
off our debt is we kind of I I did not
get my nails done and every so often I
was able to get my hair done so it was a
trade-off because it can get expensive
if you're going every two weeks and
you're doing the hair thing and you're
doing I don't know what you're getting
your eyebrows you know whatever done it
get another thing I'm inexperienced at
you know you don't wa there just a whole
bunch of these things I don't know
anything about so the point is it's a
lot of grooming it can get expensive um
some of it it's like yeah you need
somebody to cut your hair every now and
then or you need you know whatever that
is but Nails truly is one of those
things that it is do it cost to get your
nails done
Laura it's about $50 each time so and
how often how often would this come
up
it's weeks yeah was right on the hammer
y okay all right and so I I you know I
grew up redneck hillbilly so I don't
know anything about this but when I was
growing up people did their own Nails is
that a
possibility see I worked in professional
uh industry and I have really brittle
nails and so when I don't have them done
I they look gross and disgusting I
wasn't say I wasn't say gross and
disgusting I said I mean like I mean my
my little sister and like they would
paint stuff on there do y'all still do
that I mean do humans do that do them
themselves ever no every all the women
are shaking their head yout from another
planet you can paint them but she wants
an application that's going to make them
hard so that they don't break and I will
say um Laura you can you can buy the dip
powder and you can do those yourself and
it is a lot less expensive I don't do it
but I have friends that do
it and that might be did you do it when
you weren't getting your nails done no
because I but yours weren't brittle no
they weren't brittle or I'm learning so
much today you can even buy the jar of
like the hard gel that you can polish on
and so that's that'll save your nails
without you having to get them done
where is Rachel Cruz when I need I feel
your pain though look I feel her pain is
that's a sacrifice but it's only
temporary what's your household
income we make about 200,000 and the
66,000 on the car is the only thing we
have left but who whose car is it
yours
sell the car and yeah we are so we are
that's our plan we're going to sell the
car obviously we're upside down on it so
we're g to have we're going to take our
three to six months and pay off the
difference and then I'll get like a
$20,000 car and we'll pay that off in
about three to four months and then
we'll pay the house off wa wait a minute
how much do you have in
savings we have about 15,000 in savings
and that pays off the difference when
you sell the car but then you were going
to go finance a $220,000
car yes no I don't think I would do
that
W okay so here here's the thing
um mean we had a lot of fun with your
nail question and it's fine to talk
about a 100 bucks here you make $200,000
a year you got other problems in 100
bucks so are how How Deeply do you all I
mean it feels like you cut your nails
and cut your nail budget back and he's
still buying like tools and stuff at
Home Depot or something I don't know
where in the flip is 200,000 going then
we can't pay 66 off minus 15 which is 51
in about four or five months why don't
you pay this car
off our our house payment is about 3,100
a month because we bought at the height
of interest that should be
fine okay so you have a $36,000 a year
going out on a house payment you make
um yeah I guess that's a good question
maybe we need to sit down you do a
budget we are going to start doing a
budget okay you don't cut you don't cut
your nails out until you guys get the
rest of this fixed yeah when you sit
down and do a budget that's going to
reveal the budget is like blood work it
reveals everything going on where the
money's going where the problem is and
so when you sit down and do that you're
going to realize oh I've got bigger fish
yeah nails if you want to cut that
that's fine but you're going to see all
the little things that's making
this difficult here here's the thing if
you guys have gone through your budget
together with a fine tooth comb and
you've slam dunked your
$200,000 income towards 51,000 because
you got 15,000 in the bank to throw at
this um I think you're going to find a
lot more opportunities to get your uh
get your goals hit very quickly than
your nails and the fact that your nails
were set over to the side is the issue
while you guys still have done the
budget um kind of makes me want to fuss
at him because he has you guys got to
get in there together and he's got a I'm
just telling you there's some crap he's
doing that's more than those stupid
nails when you get in the budget you're
gonna find it yeah yeah there's there's
something he's that he's got that's his
little pet thing and he doesn't want to
give up the gym membership while he's
making you cut your cut cut out the
nails all that I I only know this
because I'm the guy that did that kind
of stuff so um but yeah I think when you
both have a very clear print out of
what's going on like Jade said the blood
work is done the you get your every
dollar budget both of you are looking at
it both of you say we're willing to cut
deeply and then we're not going to cut
out $100 a month for this or we are
going to cut out $100 a month because
it's only for five months yeah I'll do
them myself for five months but you're
giving that over there up and we're not
going out to eat and we're not going on
vacation and we're not doing this and
we're not doing that and we're not doing
this if I'm giving up the nails that's a
fair statement are you guys putting a
lot into
retirement yeah so we actually did
complete dat the Financial Peace
University uh during the co time and we
paid off all of our debt and then we
made a stupid decision we bought a
stupid car and then we bought another
stupid car and we don't have piece
anymore so we're getting back into Fu
and you've still got your retirement
coming
out yes and my guess is it's quite a bit
it's not just 15 is it it's not
$50 no it's more than that that I arest
my case there you go okay get back on
the detailed scorched Earth baby step
two budget the two of you together stop
your retirement use all non-retirement
funding to clear this car up you're
right it was a stupid decision yes you
fell off the wagon yes you're getting
back on the wagon but that's not we
don't go straight to the you can't get
your nails done while I put 15% into
retirement that's right thank you hello
he's not following our system okay we're
telling you to stop everything and get
this done and then I may cut the nails
too not cut the nails cut the nail uh
expenditure treatment out uh whatever
the flip you call it and um anyway but
that's more symbolic with your income
that you've gotten everything else going
than it is actual yeah does that make
sense and sometimes because you're
changing Behavior symbolic things
symbolic sacrifices are valuable
okay I remember I had a old boy from the
country at Financial pece University one
time he came in big old guy and his wife
was sitting in a small group crying and
she said I love my husband so much he
just sold his knife collection and it
was like his prize thing yeah a lot to
but he said my wife and my kid's future
means more than those knives he said
1,100 bucks it didn't really matter cuz
they had $60,000 in debt but it was it
was symbolic that he's putting the
family before me woo